I'm about to tell you the story of my
life more specifically why my life ended
despite all the positive buzz around
Netflix is 13 reasons why Parrish
Jackson is opening up about why the
series can be triggering Michael
Jackson's daughter shared a viral tumblr
post with her followers warning against
watching the show if you are struggling
with depression or suicidal thoughts
quote it really did a good job of
showing how impactful words and actions
can be to other human beings but if you
are struggling please don't watch it's
something Paris experienced firsthand
after losing her father in 2009 some
people try to cyberbully me the star
recently shared that she tried to commit
suicide at 15 years old
telling Rolling Stone quote it was just
self-hatred
low self-esteem still will leave you
with this message from 13 reasons why
executive producer Selena Gomez about
why the show is important now more than
ever I want people to know that every
every single life is valuable that their
voice can be heard and that there are
people who are willing to be there for
them
[Music]